when Fed chair Jerome Powell speaks
today the fomc raised its policy
interest rate by a quarter percentage
point the markets move
that's because the head of the U.S
federal reserve is the most powerful
economic voice in the nation and fed
chairs can generally be put into two
categories Hawks are more worried about
controlling inflation and doves tend to
be more worried about making sure the
employment Market's strong but Powell
isn't one or the other here's how
Powell's mindset helped him rise to the
top and keep the FED United
the U.S federal reserve functions as a
bank for banks we look after the overall
stability of the financial system and we
have tools to do that recently most fed
chairs have been academics or economists
so he's a little bit different from the
FED chairs that we've had in the past
few decades it was never trained in
formal economic modeling but he's smart
and he's got a great staff and he
catches on after a career in Investment
Banking and law in New York Powell left
to become an under secretary at the
treasury speaking for myself that
accounted in large measure for my own
conduct at the meeting which was to be
fairly passive in 2012 he joined the
fed's Board of Governors to help guide
the organization he has a fine
reputation he should be a fine a fine
member but his practical experience and
finance gave him a different skill set
Powell hasn't been preparing his whole
life to be fed chair he hasn't been part
of this priesthood of monetary policy
theorists and so that's brought
different strengths and weaknesses for
him in the job he watches the data he
listens to what economists and modelers
say and what Financial Market people are
saying but not what politicians are
saying his prioritization of data not
economic models has meant that he's not
always a hawk economic shorthand for
those who prioritize fighting inflation
and he's not always a dove taking action
to boost employment he's a pragmatist
he's a realist he's not an ideologue and
so he's going to change his mind when he
sees the facts on the ground changing
and things certainly changed in March
2020. the toll is growing by the hour
major retailers are also going dark it
doesn't seem fair that people should
lose everything they have including
their homes over this Powell's
data-driven mentality was guiding the
largest economic stimulus plan ever
undertaken in the U.S at that point the
whole Federal Reserve board certainly
including Jay Powell are leaning very
strongly in the dovish direction the FED
can also contribute in important ways by
providing a measure of relief and
stability during this period of
constrained economic activity and by
using our tools to ensure that the
eventual recovery is as vigorous as
possible in his response to the
emergency Powell stretched his power
farther than fed chairs had done before
he got after his staff and he said we're
falling behind this thing he said it
feels like we're swimming after a
speedboat he encouraged them to really
get on top of this and they just
announced a bunch of stuff this one
weekend in March 2020. he instructed the
FED to begin a torrent of bond buying
programs to stabilize markets and
slashed interest rates that month it
bought Treasury and mortgage Securities
at a pace of nearly 75 billion dollars a
day the criticism on Powell has been
that maybe he overreacts to the problem
at the moment so you kept interest rates
too low when maybe you should have been
more concerned about the risk of an
inflation shock that risk became a
reality fat Holdings had reached nine
trillion dollars and inflation had hit a
40-year high as Americans well know it
remains painfully High Powell had to
Pivot again and tried to keep the fed's
rate setting committee or fomc voting
together to get policy passed he began
acting as a hawk to bring down inflation
but everything that economists thought
they knew about inflation in 2021 turned
out to be pretty wrong it's not going to
be we don't think smooth it's probably
going to be bumpy I think at a time like
this we're very fortunate to have
somebody with the temperament of Jay
Powell who listens to people understands
different points of view distills the
different pieces of information that
come in
to the fed and makes considered
judgments about what to do and then goes
and persuades people that may be on one
extreme or the other extreme to come
into the center
and go along with the consensus Powell
kept the Hawks and doves United with
only one dissenting vote against rate
races since the end of 2021. a lot of
the people I talked to say that he's
very good at taking people's concerns
seriously making them feel like they're
being listened to figuring out what a
reasonable compromise position might be
and that I think explains why he's been
able to keep the committee so United
during this pretty difficult stretch
everything we do is in service to our
public Mission we at the FED will do
everything we can to achieve our maximum
employment and price stability goals as
he confronts an uncertain economic
landscape his empirical mindset will
continue to be tested how we look back
on Powell's tenures chair really depends
on what happens with inflation and the
economy over the next two years how well
did he handle this uncertain period what
did the economy look like in 2024 and
2025. that history is yet to be written
and I think future historians of the FED
will judge him strongly on how that
looks
[Music]